so I've been futuring which is a term I
made up um about three seconds ago I've
been featuring for about 20 years and
when I first started I would sit down
with people and say hey let's let's talk
1020 years out and they say great and
I've been seeing that time horizon gets
shorter and shorter and shorter so much
so that I met with a CEO two months ago
and I said look you know we started our
initial conversation he goes I love what
you do I want to talk about the next six
months we have a lot of problems that we
are facing these are civilizational
scale problems the issue though is we
can't solve them using the mental models
that we use right now to try and solve
these problems yes a lot of great
technical work is being done but there
is a problem that we need to solve for a
priori
before if we want to really move the
needle on those big problems
short-termism right there's there's no
marches there's no bracelets
there's no petitions that you can sign
to be against short-termism I tried to
put one up and no one signs so weird um
but it prevents us from doing so much
short termism for many reasons has
pervaded every nook and cranny of our
reality I just want you take a second
and just think about an issue that
you're thinking working on can be
personal it could be at work or it could
be moving needle world stuff and think
about how far out you tend to think
about the the solution set for that
because short-termism prevents the CEO
from buying really expensive safety
equipment they'll hurt the bottom line
so we get the Deepwater Horizon
short-termism prevents teachers from
spending quality one-on-one time with
their students so right now in a mayor
a high school student Rob's out every 26
seconds short-termism prevents Congress
sorry if there's anyone in here from
Congress um not really that sorry um
from from putting money into a real
infrastructure bill so we get is the
i-35 bridge collapse over the
Mississippi a few years ago thirteen
killed it wasn't always like this we did
the Panama Canal pretty much of a
radicand at Global Polio we did the
Transcontinental Railroad the Marshall
Plan and it's not just big physical
infrastructure problems and issues
women's suffrage the right to vote but
in our short term is time where
everything seems to happen right now and
we can only think out past the next
tweet or timeline post we get hyper
reactionary so what do we do we take
people who are fleeing their war-torn
country and we go after them we take
low-level drug offenders and we put him
away for life and then we build
McMansions without even thinking about
how you're going to get between them and
their job it's a quick buck now the
reality is for a lot of these problems
there are some technical fixes a lot of
them I call these technical fixes
sandbag strategies right so you know
there's a storm coming the levee is
broken no one's put any money into it
you surround your home with sandbags and
guess what it works storm goes away the
water level goes down you get rid of the
sandbags and you do this storm after
storm after storm and here's the
insidious thing a sandbag strategy can
get you re-elected a sandbag strategy
can help you make your quarterly numbers
now if we want to move forward into a
different future than the one we have
right now because I don't think we've
hit this is not 2016 is not peak
civilization I think there's some more
we can do but my argument is that unless
we shift our mental models and our
mental maps on how we think about the
short it's not going to happen
so what I've developed is something
called long path and it's a practice and
long path is in a kind of a one-and-done
exercise I'm sure everyone here at some
point has done an off site with a lot of
post-it notes and whiteboards you do a
lunge laughing and you do you do no
effects the consultants interviewed that
um and you do a long-term plan and then
two weeks later everyone forgets about
it right or a week later if you're lucky
three months it's a practice because
it's not necessarily a thing that you do
it's a process where you have to revisit
different ways of thinking for every
major decision that you're working on so
I'm going to go through those three ways
of thinking
so the first transgenerational thinking
I love the philosophers Plato Socrates
Harbaugh's Heidegger I was raised on
them but they all did one thing that
didn't actually seem like a big deal
until I really started kind of looking
into this and they all took as a unit of
measure for their entire reality of what
it meant to be virtuous and good the
single lifespan from birth to death but
here's a problem with these issues they
stack up on top of us but because the
only way we know how to do something
good in the world is if we do it between
our birth and our deaths
that's what we're programmed to do if
you go to the self-help section in a
bookstore it's all about you which is
great
unless you're dealing with some of these
major issues and so with
transgenerational thinking which is
really kind of transgenerational essex
you're able to expand how you think
about these problems what is your role
in helping to solve them now this has
been something that essentially done
with the security council chamber it's
something that you can do in a very kind
of personal way so every once in a while
if I'm lucky my wife and I like to go
out to dinner and we have three children
under the age of seven so you can
imagine it's a very peaceful quiet meal
so again we sit down and like literally
all I want to do is just like eat and
chill right and my kids have a
completely and totally different idea of
what we're going to be doing and so my
my first idea is my is my sandbag
strategy right it's to go into my pocket
and take out the iPhone and give them
frozen or some other best-selling game
thing um and then I stop and I have to
kind of put you know come doing this I
have to put on this transgenerational
thinking cap I won't do this in the
restaurant because it'd be bizarre but I
have to I did it one so that's how I
learned it was bizarre um and you have
to kind of think okay I can do this but
what is this teaching them so what does
it mean if I actually bring some paper
or engage with them in conversation it's
hard it's not easy and I'm making this
very personal it's actually more
traumatic than some of the big issues
that I work on in the world is
entertaining my kids at dinner but what
it does is it connects them here in the
present with me but it also and this is
the the crux of transgenerational
thinking ethics it sexes them up to how
they're going to react with their kids
and their kids and their kids second
future thinking when we think about the
future 10-15 years out
Stevi vision of what the future is you
have to give it to me but thinking in
your head and what you're probably going
to see is the dominant cultural lens
that dominates our thinking about the
future right now technology so when we
think about the problems we always put
it through a technological lens a tech
centric a techno utopian and there's
nothing wrong with that but it's
something that we have to really think
deeply about if we're going to move on
these major issues because it wasn't
always like this right the the ancients
had their way of thinking about what the
future was the church definitely had
their idea what the future could be you
could actually pay your way into that
future right and luckily for Humanity we
got the Scientific Revolution from there
we got the technology but what has
and by the way this is not a critique I
love technology there's everything in my
house talks back to me from my children
to my speakers to everything but we've
we've advocated the future from from the
high priests in Rome to the highly
priests of Silicon Valley and so when we
think well how are we going to deal with
climate or with poverty or homelessness
our first reaction the thing about it
through a technology you know it's
technology lens and look I'm not
advocating that we go to this guy this
is not I love Jules don't get me wrong
but I'm not saying we go we go to Joe
what I'm saying is we have to rethink
our base assumption about only looking
at the future in one way only looking it
through the dominant leg because our
problems are so big and so vast that we
need to open ourselves up and that's why
I do everything in my power not to talk
about the future I talk about futures it
opens a conversation again
so when you are sitting and thinking
about how do we move forward on this
major issue it could be at home it could
be at work it could be again on this on
the global stage don't cut yourself off
from thinking about something beyond
technology as a fix who are more
concerned about technological evolution
right now than we are about moral
evolution and unless we fix for that
we're not going to be able to get out of
short-termism and get to where we want
to be the final Talos thinking this
comes from the Greek root ultimate aim
and ultimate purpose and it's really
asking one question
to what end when was the last time you
asked herself
to what end and when was the last time
and when you ask yourself that how far
out did you go because long isn't long
enough anymore 35 years doesn't cut it
it's 30 40 50 a hundred years in Homer's
epic The Odyssey Oh Jesse has had the
answer to his what end it was Ithaca it
was his bold vision of what he wanted to
return to to Penelope and I can tell you
because of the work that I'm doing but
also you know to
we have lost our Ithaca we have lost her
to what end so we stay on this hamster
wheel and yes or trying to solve these
problems but what comes after we solve
the problem and unless you define what
comes after people aren't going to move
you know the businesses isn't this about
business but the businesses that do
consistently who break out of
short-termism
not surprisingly our family-run
businesses they're transgenerational
they're tell us they think about the
futures and this is an ad for protect
elite their one hundred and seventy-five
years old and what's amazing is that
they literally embody this kind of long
path II and sense in their brand because
of the way you never actually owned a
patek philippe and I definitely won't
this someone wants to just like throw
$25,000 on the stage up you you nearly
look after it for the next generation so
it's important that we remember the
future we treat it like a noun it's not
a verb requires action it requires us to
push into it it's not this thing that
washes over us it's something that we
actually have total control over but in
a short term society we end up feeling
like we don't we feel like we're trapped
we can push through that now I'm getting
more comfortable in the fact that at
some point in the inevitable future I
will die but because of these new ways
of thinking and doing both in the
outside world in both and also with my
family at home and what I'm leaving my
kids I get more comfortable in that fact
that something that where a lot of us
are really uncomfortable with but I'm
telling you think it's through apply
this type of thinking and you can push
yourself past that's literally very very
uncomfortable and it all begins really
with yourself asking this question what
is what is your long path but I ask you
when you ask yourself that now or
tonight or behind a steering wheel or in
the board room for the situation room
push past the long pass quick oats with
my long path the next three years or
five years try and push past your own
if you can because it makes you do
things a little bit bigger than you
thought were possible yes we have huge
huge problems out there with this
process with this thinking I think we
can make a difference I think you can
make a difference and I believe in you
guys thank you
[Applause]
[Music]